souvenez vous il ya plusieurs mois qu'on
nous avait présenté les chaînes coréenne
je me suis trompé t-shirt clairement
j'ai eu aujourd'hui vous vous présenter
les meilleures vidéos japonaise de
youtube selon moi elles sont extradés
vers son bureau extraordinaire
voici la chaîne tokaï aux nerfs c'est un
trio ils ont 1 million 700 mille abonnés
ils font des vues de ou fois répond
clairement une vidéo par jour et chaque
vidéo fut presque plus d'un million de
vues et j'ai quelque chose en commun
avec ces gens c'est que j'adore le prout
vous le savez je j'adore j'adore le foot
le foot me fera rire éternellement et
c'est bien par exemple h une mauvaise
humeur quelqu'un on est aux mureaux fait
un prout joie et de bonne humeur c'est
que c'est quelque chose de bien c'est
positif
vous pouvez dire t'es pas mature etc
mais moi je suis heureux ok mais aussi
en souffrir soit avec vous je tombais
sur cette vidéo et j'en ai regardé
aucune autre je voulais vous faire
plaisir en découvrant les autres avec
vous mais celle là et je pense que c'est
le sera meilleur c'est sûr
bien sûr vous vous dites mais que c'est
que ce bordel
1 je vous explique c'est des mecs dans
un bar empli d'un de je ne sais quel
liquide cède loup plus quelque chose
j'aime succès du slim mais je sais pas
bref la propriété pressman de ce liquide
c'est qui va retenir les gaz
du coup ces japonais malins se sont dit
et si on se met dans le liquide et qu'on
arrête pas de péter peut-être qu'à la
fin en prenant un peu de liquide
on pourra lui mais avec un briquet ça
ferait une flamme est fallait y penser
mais qui donc pendant une bonne partie
de la vidéo ils vont juste manger des
trucs et montrer leur banc puis les
prout vont arriver voilà le mec vient de
lâcher quatre énormes prouteau kahn dans
son bocal
donc il referme à chaque fois et dès que
à l'un des deux a envie de péter il
aurait omis pas dedans il le refaire
voilà c'est cette vidéo mais ils sont
donné tellement mal mec juste pour péter
szabo qu'avec ça me fait marrer et
attention messieurs dames il est l'heure
du moment de vérité on ti la cpt dans le
bocal pour qu'à l'ouverture celui ci
quand tu es une flamme ça fasse
carrément une bougie
[Rires]
j'ai réussi à faire une bougie avec leur
[ __ ] c'est le rêve de ma vie bon voilà
ça c'était une petite introduction pour
vous montrer ce qui m'a donné envie de
faire cette vidéo et les chaînes youtube
collen c'était drôle à l'échiné le tube
japonais c'est un level tu veux au
dessus c'est vraiment c'est le prout
quoi [ __ ] est ce qu'ils ont fait de
trucs sur le prout mec parce qu'on rit
je sais pas ce qu'ils font d'autres
zones motifs art whissell c'est quoi ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est nul je crois qu'il faut un test
des objets qui font des bruits de pets
mais qu on en est là ah ça c'est quoi ça
non non me dit non c'est parce que je
pense non iv mais il en train de
souffler quand tu as dis lui mais de
l'air dans les faits
mais ces chiffres sous la pile des
frissons beau jared jal un [ __ ] les
mecs on va aussi à faire détester le
prout quoi qu'est-ce qui fait l'un
qu'est ce qu'il fait là
[Applaudissements]
il lui met un dunk
non je crois qu'il mettait son doigt
dans un truc qui avait une partie de ce
truc dans son gsm me rassurer je sais
pas moi en tout cas excellente chaîne
youtube à un ultime japonaise qu'est ce
qu'elle fait au début tu comme une
agression je me suis fait agresser la au
[ __ ] c'est quoi s'attend lecture
automatique là ça part en vrille là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes mecs ils ont un délire avec le foot
c'est un truc de ouf je sais pas du tout
[Musique]
ok là je crois qu'on est sur la playlist
prout du japon pour les amis je crois
qu'on a sont assez entendu deux coups de
poing un an là à ya donc ce délire des
prout que j'ai découvert l'arrière nous
délecte que c'est pas du tout c'est les
hamsters vous saviez en gros au japon
ils sont ultra fans du mca vous savez la
vie des autres connu la du hamster qui
se bat à bouder bah voilà en quoi c'est
une meuf qu'à une chaîne youtube a
continué sa g je sais plus elle fait
plein de vidéos de sam ster tout le
temps et ça cartonne
et là bas il aime trop le hamster et
plus particulièrement le derrière du
hamster
bienvenue sur la chaîne ni ni ni hms 47
puis la bonne et c'est que des vidéos de
hamster y'a que ça mon gars derrière
dams terre volume 2 mais non est ok elle
a fait un trou dans son truc juste pour
que quand ils descendent y est c'est
fait ça me met le vexer des psychopathes
ou pourquoi pourquoi le derrière
d'amsterdam et le trouvait trop petit
regarde bien la rentrée il est trop bon
lui ils ont créé un récipient qui
appuient la bonne taille pour que quand
l'homme ça va manger dedans y est c'est
fait ce qui dépasse mais c'est de la
folie
mais laisser la mêlée c'est leur nom est
le prochain qui prend en photo ac
huningue serge de défense qui a pris en
photo ce que ce poème faire quoi [ __ ]
c'est le cul d'un homme ça choix mais je
comprends même pas de délire je
comprends pas que ce qui est fascinant
c'est le cul d'un animal c'est parce
qu'un petit pour poudre et ça mignon
aimable est mystérieusement il trouve ça
abusé real se retourne en mode est
franchement aux frères tamuz la seule
vidéo de youtube où il n'ya pas de
j'aime pas c'est le cul d'un hamster
pendant 40 secondes
est ce que c'est normal en attendant
l'un des plus sûrs l'âme soeur là et le
mec a évolué un truc de ouf et il est
passé du cud hamster au cul de 10 po
quoi c'était un rhinocéros
je sais que ça vous tracasser je sais
c'est un rhino step à un niveau
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce que je suis en train de
faire de ma ville en fait cette vidéo ça
un fit entre les trois mecs qui font des
prout et la meuf qui a déjà youtube où
elle filme ces hamsters toute la journée
bah oui non c'est parce qu'on pense
c'est parce qu'on pense l'inquiète
[Applaudissements]
nadi dr lô catholics in house tholot
genk et dsk au [ __ ] moi attend déjà
trouvé sur la chaîne du number one du
japon mais mongai fait des vues ces
intrus des psychopathes fait plus de vue
que cyprien et norman réunies en trois
jours il fait 5 millions de voeux 8
millions 7 celle là aux millions deviens
moi mais c'est quoi ce matin c'est
incroyable et c'est quoi c'est quoi
cette vidéo avait millions 700 mille dû
à celui qui parlait de plus je vends
tout une vidéo d'accord bon comment pas
de match pas comment les blagues aux il
a fait de musique attention vous avez vu
ou pas c'est le mec qui fait les protoss
en bas qu'est-ce qui fait la grosse
pointure le clip bas vidéo kojima qu'est
ce tu fais là m'ont gardé pas en train
de bosser sur le prochain metal gear
solid et comme les japonais ils sont au
direct sur nos têtes parce que c'est
tellement pas les mêmes codes que nous
que on est perdu quoi quand on regarde
ça mais ce que j'aime bien avec ça c'est
qu'ils osent ils on s'amuse les hausses
envoyer de l'air dans les fesses pour
péter isoz
enfin soit au japon gay comme ça aurait
au contraire le japon s'est basé sur
l'honneur ses traits tu dois faire ça tu
dois rendre service doit faire ta tel
rouleau ses textes mais je trouve que du
coup il ya une partie du japon qui est
complètement décomplexé ysos vraiment à
faire des trucs comme ça complètement de
nawa qui sont bat les couilles quoi ça
c'est rigolo
bon je m'en remets 25 ça je m'en remets
pas en fait les amis je découvre que sur
youtube il ya un trou de game il ya un
prout game j'avais pas j'en peux plus
non stop stop est-ce que youtube est
destiné à devenir une plate forme il ya
que des vidéos de foot qui est sûr c'est
que ça met du bac c'est une compilation
me dis pas que c'est une conversion de
meuf qui pète ça m'énervait
il faut faire une chanson tout de suite
pour stopper ce fléau
[Musique]
arrêter de pratiquer le foot il vous
plaît ça me temps même si vous n'êtes
pas méchant je pense qu'il serait plus
approprié de faire des vidéos un peu
plus travaillée de divertir sans relâche
et son sphincter de faire rire sans
avoir à péter par terre alors maintenant
sortez un peu prendre le soleil et
réfléchissez à tous et vos conseils
tous ces beaux conseil tous et vos
conseils à tous ces beaux concerts y
réfléchissez à tous et beaucoup réfléchi
c'est à tous ces beaux tous ces bons
conseils
oh [ __ ] et folle al-zawi c'était de la
passion j'espère qu'elle vous a plu par
ce petit morceau improvisé au ukulélé
vous a plu aussi ces cas n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo j'ai menti c'est pas moi
qui jouais à la guitare voix là mais je
me lâche je vais vous la jouer merde
[ __ ] j'aime tellement de découvrir le
youtube game d'ailleurs c'est tellement
différent de chez nous c'est robert en
fait c'est pas tant différents que ça
genre je sais que italie espagne france
etats unis etc
c'est très similaire mais [ __ ] les
pays d'asie mon gars c'est un autre
délire c'est trop bien je vous ai
entendu prochaine nous et merci d'avoir
regardé portez vous bien sûr tout le
monde
[Musique]
oh